All right, thanks to everyone for
coming today.
Once again, conditions are
such that we are forced to hold our
annual research symposium online
for a second year.
Sorry about that, but I'm glad that all
of you have joined us today.
Before we begin, I think
we'd like to note that
while we are meeting today, there is
an active conflict underway
where innocent lives are being lost in
Israel and Palestine.
Many of us and many of you have
relatives and families impacted by this
conflict.
The staff of the archive hopes that
the violence will soon cease and we wish
peace for both Palestinians and
Israelis.
For those of you who I haven't met
before, my name is Stephen Naron and I
am the director of the Fortunoff Video
Archive for Holocaust Testimonies.
I'm grateful to all of you for Zooming
in from other parts of the country in
the world after a long year of
Zoom-based events.
This is the Archive's fourth research
symposium.
Our fellowship program is still very
young, but I hope that you will agree,
after seeing the results of today's
symposium, that it aims to make a
significant contribution to
international scholarship about
and based upon video testimonies
of Holocaust survivors.
We established the Fortunoff Archives
Fellowship program with the launch of
the Hartman Fellowship in 2018,
where it was conceived as a fitting
way to honor one of the archive's
founders, its faculty advisor for
decades, Professor Geoffrey Hartman,
who passed away on March 14, 2016.
An eminent professor of comparative
literature at Yale, Geoffrey's vision
and leadership helped build the
Fortunoff Archive into the institution
that it is today.
Our fellowship program has grown to
include other fellowships, all named for
the four founders of the archive,
Dori Laub, Geoffrey Hartman, Laurel
Vlock, and Willie Rosenberg,
four recurring fellowships with
different areas of focus for four
individuals with whom we would
not be here today.
Beyond our founders, there are many
other individuals and organizations to
whom I would like to offer a few words
of thanks. This fellowship program would
not be possible without the support of
our faculty advisor, Timothy Snyder,
Professor Doug Rogers, who's head of
Russian, East European and Eurasian
Studies at Yale, and Jennie Shamasna
at the MacMillan Center, which is the
official institutional home of all of
our fellows at Yale.
The archive is grateful for all of your
assistance, recruiting, and shepherding
our international fellows through the
process of becoming part of the
community.
I would also like to thank our partners
at the Vienna Wiesenthal Institute, in
particular Eva Kovacs, for
providing the framework, funding and
international support for our joint
fellows in Vienna.
Finally, I would like to express my
gratitude to the Fortunoff, Blaustein,
Kohl, Hornos, Libby, and Ross families,
and dozens of other donors, large and
small, that helped make the archive
possible.
The primary goal of the fellowship
program is to encourage scholarship in
the collection and to unlock testimonies
and make them more accessible and
as intellectually as well as
accessible to users by,
by charging our fellows with the task of
producing an annotated critical edition
of a single testimony from the
collection.
I'd like to invite our Hartman Fellow,
Gil Rubin, to tell us more about the
critical edition series, as well
as well as introduce our speakers today.
Gil?
Thank you, Stephen, so I'm just going to
speak, just for a few minutes, I'm
going to introduce our Critical Editions
series that was launched earlier
this year in February.
And I'm actually going to share my
screen now and tell you a little bit
about what it is.
So every year,
our postdoctoral fellows,
our visiting scholars, and various
other people associated with the archive
produce a critical edition.
And what the critical edition is-- and
does everybody see the page currently
or? Yeah, okay.
What a critical decision is, is
basically every visiting scholar
selects one testimony from our
collection and then they produce
two things from it.
They produce an introduction, which is
a text that is designed for the public,
for students, or other researchers that
places that testimony in its historical
context and situates within the
contemporary historical scholarship and
literature that is relevant for it.
So we had, we could have about, right
now we have eight different testimonies
here, eight different critical editions.
And the second thing that it does is it
actually, the researcher
and scholar, the look at the, view
the testimony, and they present and
they produce an annotated transcript.
That is once you view the transcript
online, I'm going to show it in a second,
can actually see explanations of various
words, places and so forth, that help
you kind of understand that testimony
while situated in its time and place.
So I'm going to look now at just one
testimony and one of
our critical editions and kind of guide
you through it.
So this is, this was produced by Sarah
Garibova, who was
one of the Hartman fellows here.
And what you can see here through this
online viewer is that we have an online
display of her introduction
to the testimony that presents kind of
the general historical background, but
also situates with the relevant
literature.
You can click on the various footnotes
here and get
either more information or other sources
that are relevant.
And this is how it's been viewed online,
from the landing page to viewing each
and every testimony.
And then, if you have if you want, you
can actually hear their songs in the
testimony.
So they will open up and you can
actually listen to this,
in this case, the edition
she worked on includes a song that was
later reproduced also
in our Songs From Testimonies project.
And additionally, beyond this, you can
actually go online and view the
testimony that is open, open
to everyone to view.
I'll just open here, and
view it together with an
annotated transcript. [CLIP OF TESTIMONY
IN RUSSIAN]
So I'll just show how it works.
So you can see over here, once there's a
word that
requires any type of explanation.
So you can see here
Dr. Garibova's explanation on this
specific word, on this specific concept
and this specific idea that is presented
in the annotated transcript.
So the idea here is actually to take our
testimonies that are often accessible,
either in specific language to a
group of researchers or people speak the
language and bring them to researchers
might not work on this specific subset
of testimonies and languages, bring them
to students, and bring them to the
public.
And so far, within the Critical Edition
series, we have eight different
critical editions and we hope to add
more throughout the year.
And actually three of the talks
that we are going to hear
today are, are actually
going to turn into critical editions.
And I think the speakers will present
more about that.
I will, I will add now to the chat
a link to our critical edition series.
And I'm happy to answer any
happy to answer any more questions about
this. But I just wanted to kind of
present here both so we can celebrate
and announce the publication of the
series, which was
the result of a lot of effort of work by
our scholars and other people
at the archive, and also
kind of give context into some of the
talks that we'll hear today and see
actually how these critical editions are
created and the type of questions
and issues that the scholars are
grappling with as they produce it.
So I'm going to put it in the chat
in a minute.
But before we do that, I'm just going to
present our first speaker for today.
So basically how it's going to work, we
have two sessions.
So Chad Gibbs and
Julie Dawson are going to present first
and then we'll have a Q&A session, and
then we will hear presentations
from Wendy Lower and Jonathan
Petropoulos.
And I'll just start with a short intro,
a short biography of Chad,
and then I'll give him the floor and
let him speak.
Chad Gibbs is a PhD candidate at the
University of Wisconsin, Madison, and
the inaugral Dori Laub Fellow at the
Fortunoff Video Archive for Holocaust
Testimonies.
And we want to congratulate him, that in
the fall of 2021, he will take up
the position of assistant professor of
Jewish Studies and director of the
Zucker/Goldberg Center for Holocaust
Studies at the College of Charleston,
and he works on resistance at Treblinka.
And his work on the topic was supported
by fellowships from the United States
Holocaust Memorial Museum, the USC
Shoah Foundation, and the George L.
Mosse program in history.
And today he's going to present about
his work, about resistance in Treblinka.
And I'll just give you the floor
and let you present.
And.
Stop sharing.
Have you? Oh, there it goes.
All right, thank you for that
introduction. We're seeing my screen OK?
All right. On the occasion of Samuel
Willenberg's passing in 2016,
media outlets around the world mourned
him as the last Treblinka death
camp survivor.
Many outlets ran stories and obituaries,
prominently featuring that word last.
Two days later, though, the Times of
Israel corrected itself by running
another story entitled, quote, "There
Are Still Treblinka Survivors Among Us.
One Tells His Tale," unquote.
Having seen earlier reports, the
daughter of Leon Rytz reached out to
the press to tell of her father's
experiences.
Rytz still lives in Sweden, where he
settled not long after World War II.
He's well known there, but his story
hadn't come to the attention of the
press outside of Sweden.
After the Times and other outlets wrote
about Rytz though, a new framing of
survival at Treblinka began to take
hold.
The Times subsequently relabeled
Willenberg the final survivor of the
August 1943 Treblinka
prisoners revolt, with italic
emphasis.
Leon Rytz, as she explained to Amanda
Borschel-Dan of the Times, escaped
Treblinka before the now famous August
2, 1943, revolt.
Rytz also survived several other
camps.
These facts led Borschel-Dan
questioning, left her questioning how
we should label his experiences.
She wondered whether it
was factually correct to call Rytz
a Treblinka survivor because he was also
imprisoned at Majdanek, Buchenwald,
and Bergen-Belsen.
Borschel-Dan took her question to Yad
Vashem's Ehud Amir, who
assured her that there's, quote, "no
binding definition of how a Holocaust
survivor is labeled.
A person who is in several camps can be
considered a survivor from each camp in
which they were a prisoner," unquote.
The passing of Samuel Willenberg and the
late recognition of Leon Rytz opened
new conversations in the media.
Noting as they did the different kinds
of survival stories told by Willenberg
and Rytz, media outlets began
to qualify different versions of
survival at Treblinka.
Willenberg became the last Treblinka
revolt survivor, while Rytz holds
center stage as the last living survivor
and a pre-revolt
escapee.
Amir's explanation highlights
the fact that there's no commonly
understood way to label Holocaust
survivor experiences.
And in addition to this, at present,
there's no historiography of the term
"survivor" as it relates
to a specific place like a camp,
ghetto, or shooting site.
Many historians and organizations
offer capacious and respectful
definitions of the wider term "Holocaust
survivor." But I don't think we have
looked at how the term "survivor" can be
employed locally and what that might do
for research.
I think that lack of place, specific
understandings of survival is
particularly noteworthy
with the vibrant expansion of spatial
Holocaust research.
But as they reacted to the passing of
Willenberg and the late emergence of
Rytz, reporters began an
exploration of these questions and what
their answers might mean for
understandings of the Holocaust.
A revisitation of survival at Treblinka
offers opportunities to analyze
what it means to be a survivor a certain
place during the Holocaust, as
well as a chance to assess how many Jews
made it out of this extermination
camp, and how they did so.
Defining survivorship for individual
Holocaust locations like the thousands
of camps and ghettos of the Nazi system
is an essential step for historians
seeking to clarify the roles, uses
and evolutions of those sites.
At Treblinka, the varied means of
survival represented by people like
Willenberg and Rytz also point to
a need for like, some,
basic categories of survivor experience.
Research that defined survival of
certain places can, for instance, help
scholars understand the reach and
influence of a site beyond its seemingly
discrete fences, walls, or
borders like that.
My own interest in survival
at Treblinka and finding out how many
people survive this place comes from
my work's need to deal
with a well accepted
number of survivors at Treblinka.
Many in this audience and other
panelists here might, might know
the number 68, that might jump out
at them as the
accepted number of survivors at
Treblinka.
And that number comes from the 1979
book The Death Camp Treblinka,
an edited volume by a man
named Alexander Donat, who was himself
a Holocaust survivor
and had been in the Warsaw ghetto.
He listed 68 people that he was able
to find in the process of his research
in the mid-70s.
And though he said at the time
that that list was anything
but, I think his
exact words were are anything
but exhaustive, it's
pretty much gained a canonical
acceptance.
When I begin talking about my work
at a conference or something like that,
I usually get the question, how do you
do work on Treblinka?
There were only 68 survivors.
It happens quite a bit.
It's a very well accepted number.
But I have looked at this
matter of how many people survived
Treblinka and come now to,
after a lot of archival work throughout
my dissertation research,
come to 251
named or identified survivors
of the camp and come
up with three main ways in which
they survived Treblinka.
So of those 251
people, 71 are
revolt survivors like Isadore H.
from the Fortunoff Archive.
And that category
kind of, it seems to jump out
as the most easy to explain
category of survival experience at
Treblinka.
But it gets it gets somewhat murky
and it is instructive for finding the
boundaries of the camp.
So Isadore H.
escaped Treblinka on
August 2, 1943 during
that that prisoner revolt.
He took part in the revolt, but if
I'm looking at whether or not to put a
person in that category, I don't require
that they took part or even knew that
resistance was going to take place that
day. For me, it's enough that
they saw the revolt taking place and
wisely made for the fences, as everyone
else did.
Where the category gets instructive
about the limits of Treblinka local
power, is in looking at
the, so about 300 people
made it out during the revolt, but we've
only identified 71 of
those individuals.
Many lost their lives in, in
the chase away from Treblinka,
or were perhaps,
some were caught by locals
and brought back to the camp in
search of, in hope of a reward,
so on and so forth.
So in looking at how
far they got away from the camp
after how much time they were brought
back, I believe that in that we can kind
of see the local power
of Treblinka and its, and its
perpetrators.
The second group
of individuals that I look at,
a larger group that is that I look at,
is escapees.
And to disambiguate that term, I mean,
anyone who escaped Treblinka
on a day other than August
2, 1943.
It's, to my knowledge
it is only these 74
people are the only individuals who
escaped before the revolt.
So sometimes they escaped in...random
acts, unplanned acts,
I should say, and sometimes they
escaped in kind of smaller
scale, networked,
preplanned events where
they, and I think the largest
I've seen is about nine others
got out at the same time, by
coming up with and planning a means to
escape the camp.
And what they do and what looking at
this category and its,
and its timeline, especially because
there's a certain date at which about
January of 1943
at which escape from Treblinka really
comes to an end.
This option of resistance,
this option of trying to survive the
camp kind of stops being
viable.
And that is because there had been
so many escapes, you'll notice that
number is just, it's pretty large,
I believe, for a camp that only operated
for 11 months, and
larger than our previous
knowledge of how many people who
survived at all.
And in that, it instructs
as to how big of a problem
escape was for the Nazi
guards who ran Treblinka.
So much so that in January of '43,
they opened a new barracks building that
basically cut off this version of this,
of survival.
But at the same time,
that was something of a putting out a
bonfire by starting a forest fire,
because once they moved all Treblinka
prisoners to that new barracks,
prisoners testimonies then start
to say, well, now we could plan
a revolt because we could all talk to
each other in the barracks at night.
So that was a pivotal turning point
in Treblinka history brought about by
this form of resistance by escapes
prior to the revolt.
And finally, there's one last major
category that I want to cover.
Perhaps I'll have to leave some of it
for Q&A if we want to get there.
But I called this last group
through-transport survivors, and this
sort of changes our understanding
of how the Nazis used Treblinka
as a part of the wider Holocaust,
because the certain timing of
people who were brought to Treblinka,
stepped off the train,
and were then put back on a train
to somewhere else, tells us about
the camp's role in wider perpetration.
So, Ben L.
here, who was
incredibly shocking for
me to find because it turned out that
Ben L., his,
his family is actually third
generation Wisconsin Badgers.
So I ended up finding out that
a current undergrad at
my own university is a descendant of,
of this man.
And these people came in about
two different ways that came as the
Warsaw Ghetto Uprising was taking place,
and they also came as
a resistance was going on in the
Bialystok ghetto.
And in a longer explanation,
I could get into how that really informs
us about Treblinka's, how Treblinka
fit into these other events,
and how those other events changed what
went on at Treblinka.
That being my last major case,
if you've been following along quickly
with your calculator or something,
you'll notice that the numbers don't
entirely add up, and that's because
there are some individuals
their, their trip, their story doesn't
exactly give us enough information to,
to say for certain how they survived.
And there are a few very unique
cases, but I
couldn't get into those in the amount of
time here.
So just
to, to wrap up,
Leon Rytz, the media's, quote,
"last survivor of Treblinka,"
may well be the last living voice of
survivor survival at this
extermination camp, though
it's impossible to know for certain.
I think that's the most important thing
to point out about any making of a list.
The fact that a Treblinka survivor would
now be nearing 100 years old
makes it likely that Mr. Rytz
is alone in his experiences.
Similarly, the increasing age of all
but the youngest child survivors of the
Holocaust means that these last
experience and last voice
news stories, I think will sadly
only increase in the coming years.
As they do, journalists like
the Times' Borschel-Dan will struggle to
find prudent and respectful ways
to describe the lives and paths of
the people they cover.
Historians, I think, would be would do
well to get ahead of this coming wave of
media definitions by providing their
own.
This, however, is not the only reason
that scholars should address the
definition of survivorship at the places
they study.
Research on Treblinka demonstrates
that we should be prepared to find
another kind of last survivor
of the camp.
Many individuals now
passed away remain unacknowledged
survivors of this place.
The permanently incomplete nature of any
survivor list means that even after Mr
Rytz leaves us, others who
survived will still await recognition.
Defining place-specific
survival can advance our understandings
of localized perpetration, the
actions of victims and context,
and a spatial reach of individual sites
of Holocaust criminality.
Revolt survivors compel us to consider
where the bounds of this camp stopped,
complicating any simplistic view of
the fences as its
bounds of perpetrator power.
Escape survivors, meanwhile, provide an
important understanding of how Jewish
resistance changed the very face
of Treblinka and helped create the
conditions needed for revolt planning.
Through-transport survivors take us,
take our knowledge of resistance other
than revolt still further,
while also allowing us to see how
Treblinka fit into the wider Holocaust,
as well as how camp routines changed
over time.
I don't propose a single definition
of place-based survivorship.
I think that many of the over 44,000
camps and ghettos of the Third Reich
will require unique understandings.
The thousands of mass shooting sites
may demand still more reckonings with
the idea of survivorship.
Localized definitions, though, will help
scholars seeking to understand the
experiences, choices and paths
of the individuals they studied who
were forced to confront Nazi genocide.
Spatial studies of the Holocaust will
benefit still further from this means
of determining the boundaries of their
studies and how they fit into
overall trends.
Finally, the active idea
of defining survival in a capacious
and respectful manner makes it possible
to honor the stories of the people
that we study.
Increasing the number of survivors of a
place like Treblinka that killed as many
as 925,000
from 68 to
251 in no way alters its overwhelming
lethality.
The importance of my work for the
history of Treblinka is instead the
creation of an update to Donat's list
that's more capable of foregrounding
the differences and individual paths to
survival and demonstrating to
interested researchers that additional
testimonial evidence awaits their use.
The stories of those left off Donat's
list deserve recognition and inclusion
by future scholars, even while we
continue to acknowledge that no list
will ever be complete.
Thank you.
I'll stop sharing now.
Thank you, Chad.
Thank you so much for your talk.
I'll just remind everyone that you can
leave questions in the Q&A and that will
take them after Chad's talk.
It was a wonderful talk and super
interesting. I think it's going to tie
to some of the other things we're going
to hear today.
Is somebody raise his hand?
Jonathan? Sure.
I did raise my hand, at least virtually.
Thank you, Chad, for an excellent talk.
Very interesting.
I wanted to ask you about the
through-transport survivors.
I confess, I had not heard about people
arriving at Treblinka and then diverted
and sent elsewhere.
Could you elaborate and tell us a bit
more about what the purpose was
and what the experience was like for
those through-transport survivors?
Thank you.
I think, So there's two...
two more prevalent experiences among
that group.
Number one is that individuals
would arrive at Treblinka sometimes and
the train would stop at Treblinka II,
the extermination camp.
And then at times, the labor
needs of Treblinka I,
the nearby labor and
penal camp, which
is often said to have been for Polish
prisoners, but it had a large Jewish
population as well.
Sometimes that camp's
needs, if we want to put it that
way, would be met
by taking people off of the train at
Treblinka II, and putting them back
on, sorting
them if you want, and putting them back
on a train to Treblinka I.
And we learn about resistance in this
moment, even if it's a very
short period of time, because a lot of
stories are told about how, how people
tried to look ready for work,
how they tried to jump into a line
if they saw that, you know, this was
the right line to be in.
So there's a lot of very quick thinking
resistance that's like short episodes,
but very important and saves many
lives.
That other group is
usually sent on to Majdanek.
So, at the time of the Warsaw
Ghetto Uprising particularly,
I'll just simplify things by staying
on that one topic with this answer.
At the time of the Warsaw Ghetto
Uprising, it seems that the
Nazis tried to push the
population of the Warsaw Ghetto out on
trains as fast as they possibly could,
and that meant that they didn't sort
probably in the way that they normally
did, and people were instead
sorted at Treblinka.
And then those thought fit for labor
were place back on the train and sent
to Lublin-Majdanek.
So that, that experience
happens at basically two different
times. It's kind of the same episode,
the same reasoning going on, but
it occurs at the time of the Warsaw
Ghetto Uprising and at the time of
resistance in the Bialystok ghettos as
that is being closed.
Excellent, excellent.
Thank you, very, very helpful.
Out of curiosity, what was the survival
rate at Majdanek for the people who were
sent on their,
probably very, very low as well, I
would presume.
It's, yeah.
So it's it's very, it's low, it's not
good. However, it's,
it's way better, you
know, it's way better than if they had
stayed at Treblinka where there's
basically, other than the revolt,
once you're in the camp, if
you can't get out in the revolt or you
can't escape on your own, it's almost
certain death.
Being sent on to Majdanek
after you've already been chosen,
quote unquote, "fit for work,"
the chances of survival are
much, much better than had you not
stayed or then had you stayed at
Treblinka. So it's, um,
a lot of those people do lose
their lives later, either through
being worked,
worked far too hard at wherever they
were sent next, but,
you know, I didn't actually say in the
talk that I count someone as a Treblinka
survivor even if they die later in the
Holocaust. And I know of many
individuals who fit
that explanation.
But I think that we need to keep them
there because, you know, that doesn't
change the one event in their life to
have to have perished
in another incident.
But, yeah, it's still bad,
just to sum up. But
so much better than, than staying
at Treblinka.
Thank you both.
With the rest of the questions, it seems
there is another question from Professor
Avinoam Patt, but we'll take them, I
think, after Julie's presentation just
we kind of take the questions then.
That's fine, I mean, I could have,
but so I'll just
present Julie briefly.
And then after Julie's presentation,
we're going to have a Q&A session
with both Julie and Chad.
Julie Dawson is the Fortunoff
fellow at the Vienna Wiesenthal
Institute and a doctoral candidate
at the University of Vienna's Institute
for Contemporary History.
Her dissertation examines postwar Jewish
life in Romania through the lens of
recently found diaries of a
Transnistrian survivors.
She worked for the Leo Baeck Institute
from 2010 to 2019
and directed their archival survey of
Transylvania and Bukovina from 2012
to 2019.
And she was a researcher in
Medias, Romania for the
EU Horizon 2020 project
called TRACES: Transmitting Contentious
Cultural Heritage with the Arts.
And she's published several articles
which you can see on her
website,  under her, on her bio on her
website and her research more generally
includes Jewish Bukovina, Communist
Romania, women's history, trauma,
and memory studies.
And I'll let you start presenting Julie.
And please write any other questions you
have for either Julia and Chad in the
Q&A session.
And we will discuss them briefly.
OK, thank you.
I'm going to share my screen.
All right.
All right, thank you very much,
Gil and Stephen and the Fortunoff
Archive for the invitation and
support.
My project is
somewhat different from the other
presentations as my focus is not on
oral histories per se, but rather
on this newly discovered written
testimony that Gil mentioned, a set of
diaries written in the immediate
postwar period in Romania.
Due to the nature of the diaries,
however, consulting oral histories is
crucial for contextualizing my subject's
Holocaust experience.
And then I use oral histories to
complement and expand my subject's
writings.
I'm also only a little halfway through
my fellowship.
I took maternity leave partway through,
so my research is still ongoing,
I view new material every
week, every day and gain new insights
all the time.
In this short talk, I'm going to
introduce my overall project with the
diaries as the core analytic lens.
I'll give some biographical background
on the author, of just a tiny bit into
trauma theory, and discuss my
continuing examination of the associated
oral histories.
So, the diary.
One spring day in 2009, a
peach colored notebook was discovered
by volunteers cleaning up a
document-littered woman's balcony
of a shuttered synagogue from a small
Transylvanian town.
The notebook, it quickly became clear,
was a diary, filled from cover to cover
with carefully pencilled German, the
words very clear to read
and often distressed.
Eventually four notebooks and several
related papers were found.
Containing over 800 entries, the diary
stretch from 1948 to
1961 and record the postwar
life of brief and limited triumph
of a young survivor of the Transnistrian
Holocaust, Blanka Lebzelter.
These diaries are a tremendous tool for
researchers.
They provide multifaceted entry points
for examining daily life of Jewish
survivors in the initial decades after
the war, as well as for analyzing
the repercussions of violent trauma to
everyday life.
They indicate spaces in which
individuals were able to perform acts of
agency despite totalitarian strictures
and also those places where the cold
machinations of the totalitarian state
devastated individual lives.
They, moreover, shed light on cultural
and social practices, and Jewish life
at the time with especially fascinating
insights into the operations of
Romanian Zionist youth organizations
in the late 1940s, about which
little to nothing has been written to
date.
Furthermore as an inherently gendered
source, the writings testify to the life
of a young single woman raised
at the interface of tradition and
modernity, struggling for a voice
in the profoundly patriarchal nation.
Finally, the author's narration of
global events from the founding of the
state of Israel to the 1956
Hungarian uprising, as well
as political and cultural responses to
the Holocaust, such as the establishment
of German reparations and the
publication of Anna Frank's diaries,
indicate an interconnectedness to
the world that belies and soon the
impermeability of the Iron Curtain.
So, who was Blanka Lebzelter?
Blanka Lebzelter was born near or in
Czernowitz in the early, mid, early
to mid 1920s.
Her father, Josef Lebzelter, was a civil
servant during the Austro-Hungarian
period, fill, filling
official clerical duties in several
Bukovinian villages and towns.
Her mother, Anna, grew up in Czernowitz
and her family overlapped with the
social circles of Paul Anschel, later,
the poet line Celan.
Lebzelter's first cousin, Gustav
was, Gustav Chomed, was close
boyhood friends with Anschel and in
postwar correspondence, the two wrote
nostalgically of Gustav's
home and the Topfergasse, this
being also the home of Lebzelter's
grandparents and aunt
and uncle.
The Lebzelter family were entrenched
German speaking Central European Jews.
Her older brother had recently graduated
from the University of Prague in
Architecture; her fiance had studied
medicine there.
Her father, most recently secretary of
the Waschkoutz town hall was in his 60s
at the start of the war, living in quiet
retirement, in a home with
a garden full of fruit trees and a
small riverside town short train ride
from Czernowitz.
The Lebzelters were generally
assimilated and marginally religious,
probably in the inferred manner
explained in one testimony
from Pearl Taub of Czernowitz,
who, when asked about her family's
religious observance and education
demures, but when asked specifically
whether her mother lit candles on Friday
evenings, answered, "Oh, definitely,
yes. Yes." When
the war broke out, Lebzelter was
probably 19 or 20.
She was well educated, speaking, besides
her German mother tongue, Romanian,
Russian, English, most likely
she understood Yiddish and Ukrainian.
She had a deep appreciation for theater,
literature, and the arts, distinct
distaste for manual labor,
and was deeply ashamed of depending
on charity.
In the summer of 1941, after the
Barbarossa operation began, the Romanian
army invaded northern Bukovina,
which had been occupied by the Soviet
Union the previous year.
During the first few weeks of July,
1941, pogroms were carried out in
countless villages in this region.
Perpetrators included Romanian soldiers,
Ukrainian and Romanian peasants, as well
as a German Einsatz troop.
And in Lebzelter's home of Waschkoutz,
the Jews pulled from their houses and
gathered at the gendarmerie.
A group of prominent men were selected
for execution, marched to a lower
hillside outside the town and shot.
Among these Lebzelters, father and
brother, Josef and Bruno, her fiancee,
she learns, was similarly murdered in a
different location.
Lebzelter and her mother, Anna,
were later deported to Transnistria,
where they spent three years in the
Moghilev ghetto.
Upon their release in 1945, the women
returned initially to Czernowitz.
Regarding this homecoming, Lebzelter
writes, quote, "The hour arrived
where we saw appear in the distance the
towers of the Czernowitz archbishop's
residence.
I gazed, spellbound upon these
towers, and listened inside for an echo
of joy.
But there was nothing of the kind.
I sensed only my raw, sore heart and
worries about the future."
She goes on to explain the motives for
their subsequent departure.
Quote, "we felt poorly in the old home
upon the ruins of our lives, like day
and night, by those hard memories
and among those who are not innocent in
our tragedy.".
The two women left, making their way
eventually to the Black Sea port town of
Constanta.
Here, the diaries begin in January
of 1948 and until
1961. When she finally received her
longed for exit visa, Lebzelter
kept a record of her daily life and
struggle with loneliness, her mother's
eventual death from tuberculosis in
1952, and always
of penetrating grief.
When she left in 1961, she
passed the diaries to her cousin,
Babette Chomed, Gustav's sister,
who had settled after the war in
Medias, a town in
Transylvania.
Her last recorded words are, quote,
"I'm very exhausted.
The moment approaches to leave the old
home and seek a new one.
What will I find?
One is not allowed to bring diaries.
I could not bring myself to destroy
them. I'm entrusting them to someone
for safekeeping.
Will they ever find their way back to
me?" End quote.
These diaries were found in 2009
by volunteers cleaning up the woman's
balcony of the synagogue in the
Transylvanian town, where Lebzelter's
cousin had remained almost until her
death in the late 1980s.
My project examines these diaries
from multiple perspectives and singular
testimony representing survivor
narratives that have been little probed
and as a source allowing unexplored
insights into social and
cultural history considerations of
postwar Romania.
My overarching research question center
around trauma, oppression, and agency.
My current focus at the Vienna
Wiesenthal Institute and working with
the Fortunoff Archive is reconstructing
Lebzelter's wartime experience
in context while also
deconstructing the manifestations
of trauma and her postwar
writings.
In her seminal work on trauma and
narrative, comparative literature
scholar Cathy Caruth describes
the double telling of the center of
trauma narratives.
She writes of the, quote, "oscillation
between a crisis of death and the
correlative crisis of life,
between the story of the unbearable
nature of an event and the story of
the unbearable nature of its survival,"
unquote.
The diaries witnessed this crisis of
life, but understanding Lebzelter's
crisis of death is essential to
presenting her story.
My work with the oral histories of the
Fortunoff Archive aims to fill
this lacuna in Lebzelter's biography,
even though such a contextualization
will and must be, in its very nature,
imperfect and incomplete.
So how am I incorporating these
oral histories into Lebzelter's story?
She herself mentions Transnistria
in the diaries only a handful of times,
generally when some aspect of her life
recalls to her mind, her experience,
for example, when she and her mother are
suffering from severe hunger or
without heat, when her hachshara
group is thrown out of its lodgings
and made to stand outside in the snowy
night, when state
bureaucracy intrudes with irrational
demands.
Fine details about the pogrom
during which her father and brother were
executed are recalled in three letters
she wrote to the dead.
But regarding the years in the
Moghilev ghetto, she writes only a
handful of nondescript sentences.
Their survival, she explains in
disbelief, was, quote, "a miracle.
I cannot explain it in any other way.".
For my research, I'm looking at all the
interviews of individuals with
overlapping biographical details,
especially those who spent time in
Moghilev. Remarkably little has been
written about the site.
And so I'm looking at anyone who was
there or passed through.
A number of individuals who actually
remained in Moghilev is small.
It was a transit point, and many
arrived only to leave within a
few days.
Some who escaped from camps further east
made their way back to Moghilev or
generally tried to hide outside of the
ghetto.
The draw may have been due to the size
of the town and the resulting anonymity
possible.
Food may have been easier to come by.
Work, which resulted in food may
also have been easier to obtain.
Ideally, of course, I would find an oral
history from a woman of similar age and
background to Lebzelter who also spent
years in the Moghilev ghetto.
Thus far I have not found such an
interview.
The women, in fact, tend to be
significantly younger than Blanka
as they were children or adolescents
during the war.
These people experience,
in addition to the specific acts of
violence, the particular anguish
of losing their innocence, learning that
their parents could not protect them or
their siblings.
The other women tend to be older than
Blanka and already with children of
their own. Survival, or not,
of their children generally forms the
core of these women stories.
The men who were in the ghetto
speak of surviving with work.
It is not clear if women were able to
work in the same manner as the men.
If not, than how their survival
was achieved.
As I mentioned, I'm only just halfway
through my fellowship and I still have
many interviews to listen to,
I look forwatd to my ongoing work and
especially to writing about my results.
To conclude, I would like to quote
scholars Marianne Hirsch and
Leo Spitzer.
In a reflection on creating channels
silenced or neglected voices of the
Transnistrian Holocaust they remind us
that, quote, "Each individual story
helps to shape a larger history,
by providing it with detailed depth and
nuance. And in turn, each story
is enhanced and given broader meaning
through its contextualization within
a larger historical matrix.
Post generations haunted by stories
that have not been worked through still
find that they owe the victims this act
of attentive listening, as well as this
act of historical work, of historical
repair," unquote.
So on that note, I want to thank the
Fortunoff Archive and the Vienna
Wiesenthal Institute for enabling this
act of attentive listening and returning
a voice to the subject was unable
to publicly witness during her life.
Thank you
Thank you, Julie,
for this wonderful talk.
I think we'll open this up
for questions.
Feel free to write questions
for Julie and Chad now in the Q&A
box and we'll read them out.
I think we have a few questions for Chad
that people wrote during your
presentation. So I'm going to read them
out and just read out, start with the
first two questions, although I think
the second and the third one
tie together some, so I'm just going to
give out the questions for Chad and give
him the opportunity to answer them and
Julie, if you have something to add to
that, too, please feel free to
jump in.
So, Chad, if you also want to
turn on your video and audio so
you can add to that.
So Avinoam Patt, Avinoam Patt asks,
"what does your research suggests about
knowledge of the final solution among
Jews in Poland during the war for your
subjects, particularly escapees?
Escapees talk about encountering a
refusal to believe the reports about
Treblinka," and
Gabriel Finder asks,
"What would you consider Polish Jews who
spent the war years and the Holocaust
in Soviet Asia?
Would you consider them also as
survivors, the, kind of,
stayed within the interior of the Soviet
Union?" And then we have another
question from Oren Stier.
"So you're, you're evolving a critical
definition of survivorship.
Your brief remarks at the end about
category, about categorizing
through-transport Treblinka survivors,
even if they subsequently perished, were
murdered in another camp, as Treblinka
survivors, has a potential to shake up
the very notion of survival.
What, we do not typically classify
as survivors, those individuals who
made it through one or a series of camps
only to be murdered at the last one.
So what will this
different perspective do to
understanding of survivorship related to
concepts like resistance?"
I think all of these questions tied
together and Chad,
please feel free to answer.
Yeah. Thanks for all these questions
and thank Julie for her
excellent talk as well.
I think I'll take the first.
I'm looking at the Q&A here.
So for escapees
and what they encounter about
refusal to believe the reports about
Treblinka. Absolutely, there's, there's
a great deal of that in
oral histories and other testimonies.
It took more than a few, the
first you know, there's the first wave
of escapees were not
believed or were silenced
because the, the reality
of what they were saying was too hard
for people to bear.
But as as time goes
on, the, partly
through how many people escape the camp
and how many voices there were saying
what it really was, that
information does get out and it becomes
more and more accepted.
And testimony
from revolt survivors,
particularly individuals who were there
for more, a longer period in the
camp. They talk about later
transports from Poland, Polish
Jews arriving at Treblinka,
acting out in spontaneous
acts of resistance as they get off the
train because they know exactly what
Treblinka is.
There, there's the people have heard
about how the, the arrival area,
Treblinka, was painted to look like a
train station.
And that really, that ruse really
only worked on individuals
arriving from Western Europe.
There were Jews sent to Treblinka
from eleven different nations.
Those from Poland tended to already
know what it was.
And there was a good deal of resistance
in one form or another as they got off
the train.
Those from Western Europe or from
further away tended not to
know what Treblinka was.
And perhaps that painting
of the arrival area as,
as a, as a train station actually worked
in that way.
To the other two questions, I do think,
to Dr. Finder, I do think that
Jews who lived out the the
Holocaust years in Soviet Asia are
survivors. I particularly, I
personally like the very, very
capacious definition
of survival that's offered by the
United States Holocaust Memorial Museum
that says that anyone
who fled persecution
basically from the
Nazi rise to power in 1933,
however they get out, wherever they go,
is a Holocaust survivor.
And then to Dr. Stier's question that is
sort of connected to that.
I would say that, I see
where you're asking that.
And I think in the longer piece, I talk
about how that, that individual is still
not a survivor of the Holocaust, that
person who dies after getting out of
Treblinka, but they have survival
experiences in their past.
All of these people are victims of
the Holocaust, to be sure.
So that that terminology doesn't really
help us either. But to say that someone
who perishes at their last camp,
I would still say they're not a
Holocaust survivor because they
perished.
But they can be, they
can have a past that is,
as a survival, survivor of Treblinka
or fill in other experience
here. So I think that that just kind of,
you know, maybe it adds a back story,
looking at it in that localized context,
as you bring up there, it adds a back
story to individuals
that we were only thinking of as as
people who perished in the Holocaust,
perhaps.
But at some, at, you
know, at another level, they have
survived other things,
whatever those might have been.
And thanks for all those questions.
Thank you, Chad. And I think Joanne
here, Joanne Rudof writes that
Fortunoff defines survivors as anyone
who lived under Nazi occupation.
That's another definition.
I had a question for Julie also
here. And my question was a little
bit, if you could just expand a little
bit about, right, because, you know the
Fortunoff Archive, we have video
testimonies and you're also kind of
incorporating that with diaries.
So maybe just also, you know, both
specifically about your research, but
also generally working with these two
different forms of,
of historical documentation.
Right. And where do you see the
differences?
What do you see and what your
perspective working with both, with
diaries and with video
testimony. What is the difference and
how differently do you think you
approach and we should approach these
types of testimony?
Yeah, thank you.
It's a question I think about a lot
in particular with these diaries,
because they were found diaries
and there are other diaries
and numerous memoirs
about Transnistria and even
that take place in Romania in some of
the postwar time.
But they've been curated and
redacted.
And what
for me is particularly unique about
the sources, it's
lostness.
I mean, the fact that
actually we also don't know what
happened to the woman.
I haven't been able to find her yet as
the project proceeds.
I used to think that,
well, I'm not going to focus on that
because I have so many of the things
that I need to focus on.
But as it goes on, I'm
finding that it
seems very important to find out what
happened to her afterwards, how, if
there's any way of finding out what
happened to her and also how she used
this period that I'm writing about,
because a lot of these oral histories
are, you know they're, they
are told sort
of from a point of view of a happy
ending, even though many of the people
are traumatized for life and maybe they
wouldn't-- that goes into the whole
trauma thing, if you can have a happy
ending after what was experienced.
But, but nevertheless,
the memoirs and oral histories talk
about that a lot. How did you survive?
What did, what helped you do this?
How did, why were you resilient?
These words and
you know, this is what we don't have
from the, from the diaries.
We don't know if she ever...
what, did she consider then, that
chapter of her life just one chapter
and she put it away and she moved on.
Was she able to move or, move on in
some way?
I don't know. And to me, that is the
biggest difference between these diaries
specifically and
the letters also.
I didn't go into the letters, but the
letters contained the biographical
information that I provided.
She writes them to her deceased
loved ones, and
they are narrative in form
and
they are different.
They're more similar to the oral
histories in that sense, except for that
she did not write them to an audi--
or to what audience did she write them.
So I don't know. I could talk on and on
about this entire section of
my project about sort of what was the,
why did she write?
For whom was she writing?
I mean, she wanted the diaries to be
kept.
She finds out about Anna Frank
in the fifties and is very moved
by this. So I think about that
sometimes. But of course, she'd already
been keeping the diaries for a long
time.
If she's extremely moved by
the knowledge of that. And she in
general was a writer, she wrote a screen
book and tried to have it, I'm sorry, a
screenplay and tried to
have it published. And so,
yeah, these are all questions that I'm
dealing with.
Thank you.
If anyone has, thank you so much for
answering, and if anyone has any other
questions, let me know.
If not, we're just going to
actually move on to our next
presentation by Professor
Wendy Lower.
I'll shortly present Professor
Lower.
Wendy Lower is the John K.
Roth Professor of History and Director
of the Center for Human Rights at
Claremont McKenna
College.
Lower chairs the Academics Committee of
the United States Holocaust Memorial
Museum and serves as acting director
of the Jack, Joseph and Morton Mandel
Center for Advanced Holocaust Studies of
the United States Holocaust Memorial
Museum between, she served between 2016
and 2018, and
she was a German Research Foundation
Fellow at the Ludwing Maximilians
Universität in Munich between
2007-2012, where she introduced courses
on the Holocaust with the testimonies of
perpetrators and bystanders, and
led an initiative to establish a
federally funded German center for
Holocaust studies at the Institute for
Contemporary History.
And Professor Lower is the author of
multiple books, which you can see
listed on her profile on her website.
Among them, the most recent one is
The Ravine: A Family, A Photograph, A
Holocaust Massacre Revealed, which she
also presented about at Yale, I
think about a month ago.
And I'm sure many of you have seen also
the reviews in the press.
And I'll just let
Professor Lower start presenting.
Thank you so much, Gil, can you hear me
and see the screen?
Yes.
Great.
Well, I want to thank everybody on the
team at the Fortunoff archive and
our hosts, Stephen Naron and the
MacMillan Center. It's been a real honor
to be the William Rosenberg scholar this
semester.
And I just, you know, despite
the limitations with Covid, we really
enjoyed our time in New Haven and
our visits to the library, and our
mining of the archives there.
And just incredibly
grateful for that. And I hope that we
can return at some point and do
some more of this in person.
So let me just get right down to my
presentation.
I'm basically broken down into
kind of seven sections.
Don't be-- I'm going to keep to
my time.
But the way I've organized it is
basically to start with,
Eric Hauser is the testimony of focusing
on, his bio, his biography.
Then why I selected
him and my kind of selection process
and my research process, how I handled
this source and his testimony,
and then delve into the content
of his presentation, why he
testified, and he states so
explicitly, and I listen to that and
studied, you know, what his rationale
was and what stories he wanted to
emphasize.
And then further
in, in subsequent sections of,
to look at some of the ideas that
Lawrence Langer has presented
as like "frozen moments of anguish,"
as he puts it, memory
of, of the senses.
These were some of the elements of his
testimony to me that popped out, that
stood out, that I wanted to
delve into.
And then lastly, the material
culture part of this or the performative
part of this, how he presents things
during his testimony, the objects he
decides to bring into
his story and the documents
that he shares.
And then at some concluding questions
about the challenge of, as an
historian, of annotating
and contextualizing and
what we mean by contextualization and
the limits of that, as well as the
potential problems with over
contextualizing and kind
of decentering the
survivor's testimony
as a result. So I'm kind of grappling
with that balancing as
well as ethical
endeavor as an historian.
OK, let me just tell you a little bit
about Eric Hauser.
Here he is. My screenshot of him from
the testimony
that he, he gave.
He was born in 1908 in
Gródek, Gródek, Jagiellonski,
Poland, which is now Horodok,
Ukraine. He had two siblings, younger
siblings, a sister and
a brother.
Gródek's gentile population at
the time of his youth, barred
Jews from entering the trade guilds and
as a result, the Jewish community there
was rather poor.
But despite this, Isaac's family was
well off. His father, Moses, was a
contractor of his own business, and he
built a lot of houses and issued
mortgages to other Jewish families.
And Isaac's grandfather.
I'm referring to Isaac now,
you know, interchanging out with Eric.
He took the kind of American name Eric
when he arrived in America in
1949. So I referred to him
interchangeably as Isaac and Eric.
So I hope that's not that confusing.
So Isaac's grandfather was
the head of the Jewish community and he
was able to use his influence to place
Isaac in the Catholic high school where
he graduated valedictorian in
1926.
And the community itself from Gródek
prioritized education.
Most could read Polish and German, and
everyone read religious texts.
And like other Jewish youth, Isaac had
leftist and socialist leanings under
Polish rule.
As a Jew, Isaac was not accepted to a
Polish university and moved to
Czechoslovakia to attend the technical
university in Brno, and
in 1931 he got a master's degree
in electrical and mechanical
engineering. This is going to be really
important as far as his ability to
survive, that education.
After completing his studies at the
university, he returned to Poland.
His degree was not recognized by the
authorities and he had to take another
exam. This is something he delves int in
his presentation.
He worked as an engineer and assistant
manager for a Jewish owned oil field
in western Galicia.
And in 1939,
his family moved into a large house in
Lwów. They moved into the city
of Lwów, L'viv, Lvov,
Poland
in September '39.
With the start of the war
in accordance with the
Molotov-Ribbentrop pact, Germany invaded
western Poland.
The Soviet army annexed eastern Poland.
Lwów was occupied and
incorporated into the Ukrainian Soviet
Socialist Republic, now part of the
Russian dominated Soviet Union.
No more interwar, no longer interwar
Poland, with the break, with the
destruction of Poland.
So Isaac's, a manager,
at this moment emptied most of the
company's bank account and fled
for America,
leaving Isaac in charge of two hundred
twenty employees and no payroll.
His reputation among the employees
prevented them from turning on him.
Shortly thereafter, as the Germans
approached, Isaac was given orders to
dismantle the oil wells and equipment
to make them nonfunctional.
And he goes into a lot of detail in
testimony about the plants,
the oil fields in
Boryslav. And he's really impressed
with these, these,
the industrial materials
there and the kind of modern
features of those plants
that he still, he's still kind of
reminisces about that and his eyes
light up when he talks about it.
So, but when they're dismantling these
oil wells and they're hiding carburetors
and trying to make them nonfunctional,
this kind of sabotage to him I think is
kind of is kind of painful, but
necessary.
During the night, he took four other
Jews and they tried to escape in a car
that he had hidden nearby, he was very
clever.
And he, they, they, but he was driving
on some dark, rough roads and he ended
up crashing the car into a river.
They survived.
And is, this group, that with the four
other Jews, they managed to walk to the
railroad station.
They made it to,
caught a train to Lwów.
And the description there of the
railroad station is really memorable as
well of the German Stukas
strafing and coming down and shooting,
deliberately shooting into the windows
of the railway cars
and killing civilians.
And that was the train they had to board
and take to Lwów.
There, when he got to Lwów, he met and
married Louise Finkler
so he would be with his wife throughout
the war
and survived with her.
He couldn't find work in Lwów, so he and
his wife Louise headed forty seven
miles south to Boryslav,
where he had extended family, and he
became the head of a mechanical and
electrical department at the Boryslav
Power Plant and worked
there as the head of the workshop.
And Louise worked there as well.
They were among 13,000 Jews of Boryslav
and subjected to severe restrictions and
psychological abuse by the Soviets.
In June '41, when Germany invaded the
Soviet Union and occupied Boryslav,
a Ukrainian militia organized a violent
pogrom against the Jewish population.
Here's the location here to give you a
little bit of a geographic orientation.
This is from Thomas Sandkühler's book
"Endlösung" in Galizien.
Here we have the city of Lemberg, L'viv,
Lwów, Gródek
here. This is where he was born and grew
up, Isaac, and
he's making his way down here to
the oil fields or petroleum fields of
Boryslav, not far from
Drohobych.
A Ukrainian militia organized a violent
pogrom against the Jewish population,
an administration, German administration
soon authorized the establishment of a
Jewish ghetto in Boryslav near the end
of November, when they conducted
their first organized aktion in the
city, capturing and killing 7 to
800 Jews.
30 members of Isaac's extended family
were killed as a result.
These actions against the population
continue to take place every few months.
And even though they had papers,
Isaac had papers, that they were, that
were supposed to protect them,
they still hid during the actions to
avoid getting picked off on the streets.
In 1942, Ukrainian and mounted
German police surrounded his column
marching to work, and Isaac fled,
jumping over a fence of an oil storage
facility while being shot at.
During another early Aktion, he and his
wife went to the house of the member of
a Jewish militia who let them hide in
his apartment.
Other times, they hid for days in
partially flooded basements.
Isaac also helped build an escape tunnel
for Jews to hide, which they were able
to construct without detection.
In November '42, a forced labor camp
was established for the 1,470
Jews who were working for the oil
company in Boryslav.
And during that month, Isaac was issued
an R badge, identifying
him as a Rüstung arbeiter.
This was a very life saving document.
During the interview, he placed, he
still has the badge and he places
it on his chest,
in this kind of, in this kind of
gesture, it was clear that this was an
incredibly important document
for him, that he kept
this pass, allowed him to leave the camp
to conduct technical work for the oil
wells.
He had to pay bribes to officials,
issuing another ID card
that specified he was a specialized
engineer.
His profession obviously was important
for the war effort.
Authorities continue to kill and
transport Jews to concentration camps,
and they completed the liquidation of
the Boryslav ghetto
in June '43.
So in this last phase of
the war in April '44,
as the Germans were doing these final,
completing these final liquidations, and
the Soviet army began advancing toward
Boryslav, Isaac believed that the
Germans would kill the remaining Jews.
And so he forged to pass, another
document for his wife, and they were
able to escape the camp.
And for six weeks they hid in the attic
of a Ukrainian peasant
alongside 16 other people.
Boryslav was liberated by the Soviet
army on August 7th.
After liberation, Isaac was able to
acquire Polish papers for Louise and
himself, and they were permitted to
cross the border into Poland.
They went back to Lwów, where Isaac's
family had been forced from the Lwów
ghetto into the Janowska Street camp,
and his family was probably killed there
in 1943, when the ghetto
and the camp were destroyed, and the
city was declared free of Jews.
The couple then traveled to Munich,
where Isaac acquired a job with the
World ORT Union as
the director of the vocational school
there with two thousand students.
He provided training courses to
survivors to help them rebuild their
lives in new countries.
And in 1947, Isaac
and Louise gave depositions for the
court proceedings against the
police and Gestapo in Boryslav
and Drohobych.
Isaac and Louise lived in Munich until
emigrating to the United States in
October 1949, where
they, when they change their names to
Eric and Louise, and settled in New
York.
Here's an image of the oil fields in
Boryslav where they worked.
Sorry, this is a bit blurry.
This was the orphanage he mentions in
his testimony.
So
let me tell you a little bit about my
selection process.
And here is the document that he,
his testimony that he gave, I mentioned,
in Munich to the office,
at the office of Liberated Jews in
1947, which was held in the
Sterling Memorial, part of the
collection of the Fortunoff Archive
there, that I was able to to study as
well.
Well, I started out looking at survivors
of wartime Ukraine, today's borders,
because I'd worked on Ukraine and I
thought about it would be a good
foundation.
And then I, and I looked at
those, the ones that actually were in
English. This testimony, Hauser
gave in English, and his testimony
really was outstanding
for me because of the vivid
memories that he presented,
the image I described to you of the
German planes firing
into the trains, the fact that
he, he was able to provide that kind of
empirically rich detail, specific
names and places of people
he interacted with, the Poles,
Ukrainians, Russians, Germans
and fellow Jews.
Identifying the worst perpetrators in
the region. I, and many of those
names were familiar to me, and I knew
some of them were very obscure,
not that well known in the literature.
And yet he was calling them out
for, like one
of the chiefs, chiefs I wrote about in
Hitler's Furies actually, is the
husband and wife and, in Drohobych, the
Blocks.
Also, we have is supporting
documentation, this testimony that's on
the screen there from 1947,
which would open up another,
possibilities for research to kind of
corroborate those names and to look into
those war crimes cases.
His, the fact that he covered kind of
each chapter of his life, his youth
in Poland.
He described the inter ethnic tensions
of Poles and Ukrainians and Jews and
how that was aggravated and exploited by
the Soviet and Nazi occupiers.
He was candid about some of the most
cruel and shameful behavior,
including crimes committed by Jews,
sexual violence.
You know, he just,
there were no taboos in the way that he
presented his, his account,
and the clarity of his purpose.
He said, I'm giving my testimony and
he would stop and kind of cue the
audience, you know, pay
attention to this now.
But also the fact that he was not
in his straightforward
accounts, you know, there were a lot
of, it was very emotional as well.
And he would stop, the kinds of gestures
on the screen, the pauses,
the coughs, the
downward glances.
Sometimes he holds up the paper and kind
of hides behind the papers.
He's talking because he's getting,
his eyes are welling up.
And when he, what he says, moments when
he becomes overcome.
And the themes that are in his
storytelling of gender, the sexual
violence, the attention to women's
history, the attention to class,
talking about what he calls the Klondike
laborers in the oil fields that he
managed, the drill masters, the welders,
the blacksmiths, the rough types, he
said, who are eager to fight, whom the
Russians broke and turned it into ants
and lambs and informers.
His descriptions of race in the
hierarchies, the Nazi ladder that he
talked of, related privileges and
deprivations that were determined by
race.
So my process of, of going
through his,
his testimony was,
you know, multipronged
in a way.
First, I listened to it.
I was stopping and taking
notes, put, inserting footnotes
and various annotations, and then I
would put my own remarks in about his
manners and his gestures and facial
expressions.
I basically combined the Christopher
Browning approach of triangulation, of
testimony with other sources and various
tests of, say, probability, and,
veracity and logic.
I checked his
stories and some of his the names and
places in it and accounts against
secondary literature.
Dieter Pohl's work, Thomas Sandkühler,
Tim Snyder's work,
Kai Struve,
John-Paul Himka, of course.
Then I checked the trial
records for the perpetrators that he
identified and
many of them were indicted
in a case in Bremen and also an
important case that's occurred in
Austria, I'm waiting to get that
indictment actually from the Wiener
Library.
I went into the ITS records and found
his name on various lists
from the World Jewish Congress.
I also tried to find
his descendants.
I tried to, I found the Hauser family
in New York, but it was Buffalo, New
York, not Rego Park.
I found the wrong Hauser family.
And other family of the descendants
of survivors I talked to
actually yesterday in Buffalo, New York,
but not the right one.
So I'm trying to pursue that
as well.
So I combine this empirical approach
with what kind of Noah
Shenker and Han-- Hank Greenspan
stressed in their work on listening and
reframing Holocaust testimony
with special attention on the
performative aspects.
Because, of course, this is a video
account.
And I was inspired as well by what
the founders of the Fortunoff Archive
envisioned, that is
a collection of voices that effectively,
effectively and affectively
created a provisional community
bound by memory and the recognition
of trauma.
So I wanted to be conscious of the
manner in which the testimonies
were collected, the stories,
how they are told of human suffering,
and then the history that is then
created as a result or conveyed
and, and received.
In Noah Shenker's book, Reframing
Holocaust Testimony, he makes an
interesting, distinct-- distinction
between or among chronologically
charted testimonies.
On the one hand, the redemptive,
cathartic version, a kind of dialectic
with the interviewer, and then
the third, what he refers to as
these testimonies that contain,
in Langer's words, frozen moments
of anguish.
And this is what Hauser called in his
own self-effacing way, moments
when, as he stated at the end of his
interview, quote, "I cannot collect
myself sometimes so well.
One is overcome." So I was
interested in this on
a more conceptual side, the storytelling
that, the ruptures, the unsettled
moments, not the usual digressions
that we talk about in history
writing, but as Shenker states, those
both shattering and unifying
impulses.
So why did
our, our subject, Isaac
Hauser, why did he
testify?
First of all, the pursuit of justice.
Here, I've had this slide up for a
while.
The list of names was rather
astounding. You can, if you can read
this German document, it's also an
English translation
of, of, of the killers and
distinguishing between the Gestapo and
the Schupo. Had, you know, had
it really, had retained
that information and deliberately during
the war, documented that
and then immediately went or,
went to the Liberated Jews
Commission in Munich to to provide
that information.
Secondly, he stated, "the reason I
do this interview only I would like to
show that the Russians broke
our spirit in
a way there.
Well, the Germans killed us physically."
So there are a couple of occasions where
he compares the Germans and the Russians
and of course, in this period
in the literature especially Timothy
Snyder's work, among others, of this
notion and the politicization of the
double occupation, or the entanglement
of the Soviet and Nazi systems.
And it's, in his testimony, it became
clear to me that this entanglement,
that, that kind of characterization is
maybe not entirely correct and certainly
not this notion of a binary of a double
occupation that can be compared
as worse or better,
both qualitatively or quantitatively.
But instead, Eric, Isaac,
he describes what
he calls the kind of Russian cure
and describing it very quickly, a moment
as part of the
the radicalization.
And I guess Snyder would go back to
1933 to show how this kind of
occurs over time.
But the way that
the Russians treated
the, you know, in this first phase was
so demoralizing,
as he describes it.
He says, I'm quoting now,
"We didn't, my reason for appearing
today is I wanted to make sure, I don't
know if I did, to stress the point that
we should have resisted much
more strongly than we did." We,
as in the Jews.
"And we didn't because the Russians have
conditioned it to us.
The Russians, with their preceding
occupation, have changed us into a bunch
of low animals.
I don't know, probably lower than rats,
because I read that when rats are pushed
towards the wall, they will rear up
their legs and they will show their
teeth and they will try to bite.
The Russians have methods and the best
proof is right in the Russian history of
the last 40 years.
The Germans were murderous.
This is all well known.
There's no secret to it.
The Russian rule of calamity
is not as well known.
They didn't, they didn't liberate us.
We survived because of some skill, of
some good luck, of some happy
coincidence.
I hope the, I think the Russians helped
kill us. My father was a very strong
man. He was a building contractor.
But they wrote, they broke his spirit.
They came in.
He wasn't permitted.
They came into our house.
He took our house.
Every night, they came to try to arrest
him. Every night, he slept on the roof
because he, he wouldn't go up on the
roof to look."
Just describing this incredibly
demoralizing
period preceding the
German, German occupation that
ultimately created this situation.
Frozen moments of anguish,
quoting Langer here.
And in Hauser's
reflections about the fate of his
family,
here he describes how
his father at the moment
of the onset of the war in
'39, with the bombs falling, that his
father just became so focused
on his work, that was his
identity.
That was his his dignity.
He says, "my father was building a huge
house for Poland.
It was a huge house, a four story house
in the city of Lemberg.
He finished building it as the first
bombs were falling in Lemberg in 1939.
What is interesting for my father that
he paid his debts.
He was convinced his worth is as good.."
And then this is when he starts to get
choked up and he stops,
and he gets, he looks down, he starts
to scratch his chin and
then he kind of smiles a little bit.
"That his worth is as good...as
gold.
While the bombs were falling, he paid
his debts." And then he
describes how the Russians completely
broke the spirit of his father.
But there's a kind of critique of
his father's reaction
to the war and the first bombs falling.
And a kind of irony there as far as his
contin-- wanting to focus on work and
not realizing the gravity of
the situation.
And then secondly, when
Eric is fleeing with
with his wife to Boryslav, when they
realize they need to get out of Lwów,
he runs back during the pogrom and
his family is sitting together,
including his sister and his brothers,
younger sister and brother.
And he says, "I went in, my family was
there. I told them, 'disperse!
There is something vicious going on.'
And they said, 'no, we sit together.
We feel better when we sit together.'
And so they sat together.
They all died together.
I ran away and I hid out."
And so is this kind
of frustration that he seems to
communicate about not being able to
rescue his, you know, save his family
and convince them to, to, to leave.
And he doesn't see them again after
that.
And he assumes that they
died in Janowska.
And I'm going to show you
how that kind of follows through into
the rest of his biography, not
knowing kind of their ultimate fate,
really. I mean, what happened what
happened to them after he left
in those intervening years.
I don't know if I have that much time.
How much time do I have left?
Um, we're a little bit over time, so if
you can just, uh--
OK, then I'm going to, then I'm going to
skip through this.
I just want to point out here, we can't
read all this.
The other element of the testimony
having to do with the memory of the
senses and being attuned to
expressions of a set,
of sound, of sight, of
smell, in fact, that he describes
here, in his,
one of his intentions was to
show the total brutalization that
occurred. So he has vivid descriptions
of of the violence.
And here is a German official
who is kills,
kills his Jewish boy,
12 to 13 year old boy
who's already wounded.
And the SS man says, oh, at some there's
a discussion, should we leave this child
in peace?
The kid is afraid.
And then the more brutal German says
Solle lernen, cried the first one, he
should learn. Now that is something he
should learn.
Solle lernen. And then Isaac Hauser
says, it sounds in my ears and
they kind of finish off that child.
And similar kind of
way of storytelling where he says, "I
have to say. I saw this.
I saw this." And that's the other
account on the right that has to do with
the sexual violence, the rape of
a Jewish woman in his office by a
Jewish coworker.
These are snapshots.
Here are still screenshots of the
documents that he presents during his
interview that I wanted to pay
attention to.
And then lastly, this is a prisoner bowl
that he brought to the Holocaust Museum.
So I checked where Eric Hauser might
have donated things or given testimony
at other institutions.
And this was given in 1990 after,
after his 1985 testimony.
Why he didn't have the bowl at this,
you know, at this moment, but
his papers, is a question
I thought was interesting. But he ended
up donating this bowl.
It's a bowl he found when he went to the
Janowska camp in search of his family.
There's no, it didn't belong to
his family, it's just kind of symbolic.
It's what he has left of his family.
So my concluding questions have
to do with the Critical Edition and
how do I bring this all together as far
as both the performative,
the kind of sensory aspects
of his storytelling
and the deep memory, and then
the contextualization of that as a
historian, in the more empirical side
of that? And how far do I go with that
without kind of diminishing his
story? Or do I fill in his gaps of
memory?
And how far do I go with that in my
introduction, in my annotation?
And I open that.
And with that and I invite your
questions. I welcome them and looking
forward to your reactions.
Thank you very much.
Thank you Wendy, thank you so much for
the talk.
I'm going to present
the next talk and then we'll take some
questions at the end and please
feel free to write them in the Q&A
box.
So our next speaker is
Jonathan Petropoulos,
who is the John V.
Croul Professor of European History at
Claremont McKenna College in Southern
California.
Between 1998
and 2000, Dr. Petropolis, Professor
Petropolis served as research director
for Art and Culture Property on the
Presidential Commission on Holocaust
Assets in the United States, where he
helped draft the report Restitution and
Plunder: the U.S. and Holocaust Victims'
Assets.
He also provided expert testimony
to the Select Committee on cultural
media-- Culture, Media and Sports
in the UK House of Commons and tp the
Banking and Finance Committee of the
U.S. House of Representatives regarding
these issues. He's the author of
multiple books, which you can read about
on his profile page on our website.
Among them, most recently, Göring's
Man in Paris: The Story of a Nazi Art
Plunderer and his World,
which was published by Yale University
Press.
And I'll let you speak.
Thank you, Gil, for that very gracious
introduction. And thanks to Stephen
Naron and Timothy Snyder,
Christy Bailey-Tomecek, and all the
folks at the Fortunoff Video
Testimony Archive, it's been, it
was a wonderful semester on sabbatical.
Such an honor.
So I'm going to talk about Sydney
Bruskin.
And I would mention I
selected him because of my next
project.
I'm writing a book along with Wendy
Lower about 1945
and war's end, and what
happens to some of the Nazi leaders and,
and Sydney Bruskin's story fit into
that that project.
I had considered doing a testimony
involving Nazi looted art,
it's been my specialty.
But I found that Bruskin's testimony
was very rich and took me in a direction
I wanted to go.
So, Bruskin is an interesting figure.
He's a son of Jewish immigrants.
He's a New Haven lad,
a Yale graduate, a
member of the counterintelligence
corps that arrested French collaborators
and Nazi war criminals.
He was a liberator of a concentration
camp and a person whose wartime
experiences shaped his faith
and his identity.
Bruskin was interviewed in
1994, which was rather early for
interviewing veterans.
Saving Private Ryan, the film, came
along in 1998 and that led
to a kind of collective
project to interview the greatest
generation.
Congress passed a bill
starting an interview, a federal project
to interview veterans, and in the
first 10 years they interviewed over
65,000 but Bruskin's is earlier.
And, but it does fit into that trope
of, of, of veterans
interviews.
And I should also mention that I found
in the Yale University archives
an interview that Bruskin did nine years
later in 2003 as part
of a New Haven oral history project.
And he was interviewed by a local high
school student and reflected on his
years growing up in New Haven.
And that was useful for the first part
of the annotation.
So as I mentioned, Bruskin was the
son of immigrants.
His father and mother arrived in 1907
and 1909, respectively, from
Russia. And his father was
a barber. His mother was a dressmaker.
And, and so Bruskin
is part of a broader immigration
process or pattern.
You know, between 1881 and 1914,
over 1.5 million Russian
Jews fled persecution in czarist
Russia.
As you probably know that there were
pogroms in the early 1880s,
and then between 1903 and 1906.
And scholars say generally that the
early pogroms didn't precipitate so much
immigration, but the 1903 to 1906
ones did.
And there's one scholar, Yannay
Spitzer, who wrote, "Jewish migration
from the Russian Empire to the United
States in the years 1881 to 1914
was one of the most intense mass
population movements in history.
Over a single generation, more than a
quarter of Jewish Russian, of
the Jewish Russian population was
resettled oversea, seas.
The Russian empire was home to some 5.3
million Jews in 1897,
approximately half of the world's
Jewry." So I think to see
Bruskin as part of that process was for
me, rather, rather interesting.
Also the, let's see if
we get this.
The, the assimilation
in New Haven and what it said about
the, the local history of New Haven
was to me very interesting.
As many of you know, in New Haven, it
was called Copper City because
of the important trades in
heavy machinery and manufacturing.
And so you see these immigrants come in
and it's part of the industrial
revolution.
And so that's the story of assimilation
to me, which was quite interesting.
Bruskin went to Hillhouse High School,
still there, but it's changed its
demographic markedly.
And he, he was raised in a very
secular Jewish family.
And I'll talk about that a little bit
more towards the end of my presentation.
Very smart. Very clever.
And he was admitted to Yale
and he matriculated from
1932 to 1936.
And of course this was a period with
numerus clausus.
In 1935, Yale accepted
76 applicants from a pool
of 501.
About 200 of those applicants were
Jewish. Five got in, right,
and there was a quote from a dean
at the time, Dean Milton Winternitz,
and he said, "Never admit more than five
Jews. Take only two Italian
Catholics and take no blacks
at all." And this
continued through the 1960s.
This is quite well known.
There was a limit, a quota of
about 10 percent.
Dan Oren, 1979
Yale graduate, wrote a book that's
been well recognized, Joining the Club.
And so
Sydney Bruskin embodied
this, right. He, he actually lived at
home.
Jews and Christians at Yale
were segregated until
1948 and he didn't have enough money to
live on campus.
So he lived at home and he was socially
isolated in this way.
And it was very interesting with his
experiences there.
I love the story of the first time he
had a ham sandwich.
"I was teased into it because I wasn't
supposed to, but I could see some of the
guys were, some of the Jewish boys were
eating ham sandwiches.
So I said, 'all right, here it goes.'
I took it. And I said, oh, boy, I'm
probably going to drop dead, but I
survived." But more important,
with less levity, he noted,
"we Jewish boys accepted the fact that
there was a sort of, we were sort of
outcasts, not exactly outcasts,
but we were at the at the
edge. We accepted that and we didn't
do anything about it.
We didn't protest.".
So Bruskin at Yale,
he mentored in, majored in French
languages, French and other
romance languages, Italian.
He had some German.
He learned some Yiddish later on.
And I found this to be very interesting,
interesting. It reminded me of what
George Steiner said.
George Steiner was born in
1929 to Viennese parents who
had left Austria and gone to Paris,
and his father, who had raised
the family, the children, multilingual,
said that he believed Jews were
endangered guests wherever they went,
and equipped his children with
languages. In the Steiner household, it
was German, French and English.
But it wasn't clear with Bruskin
if this was one of the things he was
thinking about, that this would be
helpful. But he loved these languages
and it proved important in
his subsequent, in subsequent
developments.
When he graduated in 1936, he didn't
have good job prospects in the
Depression, but through complicated
circumstances he stumbled into a
bike business.
Interesting. He could not even ride a
bike. And I wondered about that, why he
couldn't.
But he was able to open a shop on Chapel
Street and I
went to look for the for the shop, his
bicycle shop, and I couldn't find
it. A little bit more research, I
realized what had happened.
It was torn down in 1961
and it was replaced by the,
the school, the Yale School of
Architecture, that controversial
building, the brutalist architecture.
Architectural historian Elizabeth Mills
of Brown had said "This
building has probably caused more, fewer
than any other American architectural
work of the mid 20th century, a storm
center from the start, praised as the
prophet of a new architecture, damned
as willful and egocentric, dogged
by misadventure, victim of arson,
student vandalism, remodeling
and endless complaint.
The A and A building has a bitter and
embattled career.
So that's what happened to Sydney
Bruskin's bike shop.
He had married and,
and so he was not immediately
drafted.
And I talk a little bit about the, about
conscription, the first peacetime
conscription in American history in
1940.
He had a daughter and that also
delayed his induction into the military.
But by 1943 he
was, he was drafted,
went through basic training at Camp
Shelby, Fort Shelby down in Mississippi
and then at Fort Devens up in
Massachusetts.
And then he was shipped to England not
knowing exactly what he was going to do.
And here is Sydney Bruskin as a, as a
private shortly after finishing.
basic training and such.
And in the U.K.,
the counterintelligence corps was
looking for individuals with
language skills.
There was a dire shortage of
individuals who could speak European
languages. And so Bruskin had his
opportunity with his language skills.
And so he became a member of the
counterintelligence corps of the 80th
division. And he
started-- well, he arrived
at, in France on
D-Day plus 30 at Omaha Beach, right, so
one month after D-Day in
early July 19, 1944.
And he was in his cohort,
were given lists of Nazi
officials and their job was to go search
for them. And the lists were published
after the war. And when I was writing
Göring's Man in Paris about Bruno Lohse,
this was part of the list.
Just to give you a sense, they had a
thick volume of high ranking
Nazis, including the Ortsgruppenleiter,
the local officials, and, and they would
go pursue, pursue the Nazis.
They started off actually with French
collaborators.
And that was kind of a training for
Bruskin as he would learn to interrogate
informants and to, to work with local
resistance and to ply his trade.
But he really became much more
aggressive when they went into Germany
and Austria later on.
And, and probably the high point for
Bruskin, certainly was a high point in
terms of hunting for Nazis, was in
Altaussee,
a small town in the Salzkammergut.
And I had spent quite a bit of time in
Altaussee myself.
It's right where the US zone
is here. It's not too far from Salzburg,
but it's in the middle of the Austrian
Alps there. And Altaussee
had been a repository for
artworks, including Hitler's
collection, over 4,500
pictures in the Führermuseum
were there, and many other looted works.
There had been drama there at war's
end as the local Gauleiter
Eigruber had ordered bombs
to be placed in the entrance to the
mine, and it took an act of resistance,
the local miners to, to, to
pull them out and defuse the bombs.
And here they are with some American
soldiers who have come in, the first to
arrive.
And of course, there was a long process
of evacuating the mines.
In the Monuments Men film, they do it in
one afternoon and in fact, it took them
four months to do so.
The roads were impassable.
So in Altaussee though, besides looted
artworks, one found an array of high
ranking Nazis, from Ernst Kaltenbrunner,
to Adolf Eichmann, to Otto
Skorzeny,
August Eigruber the Gauleiter was there.
Hugo Jury, Franz Stangl
was there, the Sobibor/Treblinka
camp commander, Anton Burger, the head
of-- you get the point.
It was just filthy with Nazis.
And so that's where, where Bruskin and
his partner Robert Matteson arrived.
And I should also mention, I had gone
and found old Nazis in Altaussee too,
in the 1990s and early 2000s.
I had interviewed Wilhem Höttl
and some others there.
So it's still a place that
has a brown past, if you will.
So Bruskin, he played a
key role in arresting
Eigruber the Gauleiter and specifically
Eigruber's wife.
That was Bruskin alone.
But, and this is, this is,
this is Bruskin in his interview
to the left, I know it is very blurry,
it's a screenshot, but gives you
a sense how they were just finding,
uh, local facilities and turning
them into prisons and arresting these,
these people.
The highlight of his
activity and hunting for Nazis
was arresting Ernst Kaltenbrunner,
the head of the Reich Security Main
Office, and Kaltenbrunner
had a villa there.
I mentioned earlier it was filled with
treasure. Over sixty kilos
of gold was found there.
Most of it disappeared.
But he took flight as the
Americans arrived and he went into the
deep wilderness there, up into
the Alps. And, and reports
came in that, that Kaltenbrunner
was probably up there in the, in the
hinterlands.
And so Robert Matteson,
Bruskin's partner took, partner took the
lead. He was very gung ho, if
you will, and he put on Austrian
hunting gear, attire.
He found some local Austrians who were,
had been in the Wehrmacht, but were now
prepared to help. And along with some
American GIs, they hiked all night
for seven hours over snow and ice
and found Kaltenbrunner and his
adjutant, Major Scheidler,
in this, this hut there.
And it was a very tense standoff,
but they managed to arrest Kaltenbrunner
without, without firing shots.
He claimed to be a physician and to be
someone else.
Bruskin was back with Kaltenbrunner's
mistress, an aristocrat
who had just given birth to twins.
Kaltenbrunner's twins, and,
and Scheidler's wife
was also there.
So when they marched these two people
back into Altaussee and Bruskin had
the women there, he was keeping them
under, under guard.
They ran to their, to their
romantic partners and they embraced
them, so that was the form of
identification with the, with the women
showing who they actually were.
And it was interesting how, how
this was such a high point in Bruskin's
career, for Matteson too, he wrote
a book about arresting Kaltenbrunner and
would lecture, and, and
they, they, they kept souvenirs,
if you will, trophies from their
experience.
Matteson kept the identity badge
of Kaltenbrunner and Arthur Scheidler's
went to Bruskin, which he still had, and
he was holding up as a symbol.
He also brought back Scheidler rifle,
which he sold in the 1990s for
four hundred dollars.
And that was kind of interesting in its
way.
Also, besides arresting Kaltenbrunner
and Eigruber and some of these others,
Bruskin went to Ebensee.
Right. And this is a photo that he took
upon arrival.
And Ebensee is a
subcamp of Mauthausen.
It, it really
came into existence about
halfway through the war,
in 1943.
It held about 28,000 male
inmates and about 11,000
of them had died in the camp.
And Bruskin's testimony
is interesting here, right.
He says, "On our way, Bob Matteson
picked me up in Kempten, Bavaria--"
Actually Baden Württemberg, but, "and we
were going on down to, to Altaussee.
On the way, we had heard that there was
a concentration camp, Ebensee, which
was not far from Altaussee, so we
drove there. Well, we got there,
there were-- Bob wrote a book and I have
at home, a sort of pamphlet-- he
claims that we broke the lock to get
in there. I say definitely, I say
that we were among the first troops
there. I remember going through this
gate and there were a few soldiers
there, very few." So
whether Bob Matteson broke the gate to
get into Ebensee or not, we're not quite
sure.
But, you know, this was the, the
scene that Bruskin and Matteson
encountered there as
liberators. And there's some fascinating
accounts of the liberation
there as the Americans, well, subsequent
to Bruskin and Mattsson
arriving, the American army arrived
in Panzers and they drove in.
And the discussion was how
the Americans were looking
at the inmates as if they came from a
different planet, that they were hardly
recognizable. And same with inmates
looking at the Americans.
Some of the inmates tried to climb up on
the Panzers, on the tanks, and the
Americans gently but firmly
pushed them down and said, no, we have
to keep away.
They brought up one or two prisoners and
gave them Lucky Strikes and said, tell
us what's going on here.
A couple who could speak English and
they were getting a sense of what
happened.
There was an interesting episode when
they went, found the kitchen there,
that the cook there wanted to give the
American liberators some
of, some food and served them the soup.
And the Americans didn't, didn't want to
do so. And they were told that it would
be rude not to accept this
act of generosity.
So they were given bowls and they took a
couple of soup spoons of the,
of the broth. And of course, they said
it tasted wretched.
It was terrible.
But this very interesting moment of, of
encounter between the American
liberators and the camp inmates,
quite a few of them died from the
refeeding syndrome that I think you all
know about there.
So there's an interesting moment with
Bruskin as he, as he
experiences this, this concentration
camp.
There was a crematorium there and
above the crematorium was this sign.
It was a little poem about the bodies
wanting to be burned and returning to
nature. And Bruskin
ordered an inmate he said was a Kapo
who was tall and well-fed to tear it,
to bring down the sign.
And, and he did.
And Bruskin carried the sign
all the way back to America.
And he put this notation
on his copy.
He donated the originals to the U.S.
Holocaust Memorial Museum.
But this was another war trophy.
Right? The crematorium sign that, that
he, that he brought that back.
And I thought that was interesting what
he was carrying all over Europe for the
next, next six months.
Eventually, Bruskin went to Nuremberg
and he was part of the team of
interpreters that worked there.
His German was not good enough for him
to be an interpreter for Kaltenbrunner,
for a major war criminal, but, criminal.
But he was part of the broader
interrogation process and then
came home in late 1940,
45,
early on in the Nuremberg trials.
This was another
photograph that he made in a Jewish
cemetery. And he captures himself
there. And one thing that I found
was really striking about this
testimony, well,
this quotation here.
Right.
"But it changed my whole outlook," going
to Europe and hunting Nazis and
liberating Ebensee, "on everything.
I had never had much of a Jewish
upbringing. We never belonged to a
synagogue. I didn't have a bar mitzvah
and so forth.
But that changed completely.
No, no. I went back to my roots after
seeing particularly the, the
camp and the women in Ludwigshafen
and so forth." He had seen
victims in Ludwigshafen on Lake
Konstanz as well.
"When I came back, I decided that I was
going to become a Jew boy again.
I didn't know how to start.
And then I got a letter from the Lodge
B'nai B'rith inviting me to a breakfast.
And any group that approached me at that
point, they were going to get me.
I signed up right away because I figure
this way I could identify myself as
Jewish." And with, Sydney
Bruskin and looking for
what happened to him after the war.
He shows up in the New Haven and in the
Hamden Jewish communities, and he's,
he's participated in dinners and
other kind of community events
and such. And, and Wendy
and I, we went and found Sydney
Bruskin's graves, gravestone,
his last resting place in the Mishkan
Israel cemetery there.
So it was interesting to see
someone who had focused so much
early on in assimilation and being an
American and
going to Yale, and then the experience
of the war, which shaped him, so,
so, so profoundly.
So. So, yes.
So mine is still
very much a work in progress.
I also hope to find
relatives of Sydney Bruskin and I
was calling Bruskins around the country.
We can see from this gravestone behind
that he has children and grandchildren,
but I have yet to to find them.
So I'm going to continue to work on my
testimony in the coming weeks
and months.
That will be done this summer.
But hopefully I can find some family
members and get that perspective as
well. So thank you for your attention.
I appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Fascinating talking, fascinating
to talk to you. I'm going to start
actually reading out the first question
and please, everyone,
please write to us with your
questions for
Professor Lower, Professor Petropoulos.
So, Lawrence Langer asks,
he writes here, "for the sake of
accuracy, memory of the senses
is Charlotte Delbo's language, which I
borrowed. My question to Wendy is,
is anything lost from the impact of the
personal ordeal of the survivor by such
extensive contextualization?
This is a question from a non historian,
not a criticism."
Well, I think, you know, I'd be curious
to hear from others on this as well, on
how to think about,
you know, is there
a balance to be
achieved or aware of?
It just, it just struck me as I
was embarking on the critical edition
and looking at the typical kinds of
introductions. And I introduced a diary
that I published years ago as well.
The, as an historian, I have
this compulsion.
I have a
routine of, as well, of
trying to check the facts
and fill out the history
and, and tell the story of the Holocaust
and Boryslav and tell the story of the
Holocaust and Galicia.
But that kind of, adding that kind of
apparatus, that kind of
either, however you want to put it,
grounding or introduction,
you know, at what point does that
then diminish the power
of the story of, of the survivor,
as you put it, the impact of that?
Because that's the subjectivity of that.
And the, and those
frozen moments of anguish, for instance,
in and of themselves are so, so
revealing. So I, that's, I don't have
really a direct answer to your question,
because as I concluded, you
know, how do we deal with
annotation and kind of traumatic
autobiographies that contain these
ruptures and unsettled moments?
Do we fill in those gaps?
Do we add layers of...do
we add to the layers of personal memory,
another layer of official history
and how much is, is
useful and
illuminating and supportive of,
of that testimony, of that survivors,
not diminishing that survivors voice?
So, I mean, I'd like to hear from Gil
and some of the other participants on
this issue if they've thought about it
in any way.
Yes, I'm going to actually tie this to
maybe something--if people want to ask
any additional questions here,
but I wondered if you want
to tie this a little bit about a
question I received for Jonathan,
also someone just wrote me.
But if, if you could
maybe discuss this and kind of discuss
also your previous work on looted art
in relation to this, and just see this
question about how does this relate to
Fortunoff testimonies?
And you can see if
any of the Fortunoff testimonies add to
that in some way.
It's one of the questions.
So this is for me?
Yeah, and I'll connect also to Wendys
question in a minute.
So, no, I'm glad that the question
was posed because it goes back to
the process by which I arrived
at Sydney Bruskin and, you know
I looked through the Fortunoff
Archives for looted art and
any references of art.
And it was striking how
art came up frequently
as part of people's lives.
And, and some of the individuals had
been artists or had, they had family
members who were artists, they had
art collections.
And, and
what I, what I took away
from reading those testimonies was
something I had sensed before
and, you know, read about
before, but it was really palpable in
the testimonies, is how art
is different
from most kinds of assets and that it's
so personal, it's
such a part of people's lives.
And, and so, you know, people
live with artworks in proximity that are
passed down from generation to
generation.
And so I did see
that come to life as people talked about
family portraits that were missing and
collections that had disappeared.
And so to see that animated
and such was striking,
you know, with, with Sydney Bruskin,
you know, the objects that he brought
back and the way he treated them.
And I think Wendy talked about these
too, what, what Hauser kept, you know,
they had a kind of a special power.
They were talismans.
And the fact that he had held onto Major
Scheidler's identification badge for
50 years was you know, it was
interesting and, and I think
representative, but, but it was almost--
Bruskin sense a kind of evilness
that was there.
And this was almost something magical
that he had that, wasn't going to
protect him, but it had a certain aura
to it and a quality and he was
fascinated with it.
So I think this notion about objects
and auras is really, really
interesting to me and connects both then
Nazi memorabilia objects and
the looted artworks that people lived
with.
And back to what
Wendy said, and I'll maybe open it also
if you have other questions, but also to
Julie and Chad even, because I think
it's a great question, I'm thinking
about what does it mean to, is there at
all, is there a risk there of over
contextualizing, if there's too
extensive contextualizing, what does
that mean for the personal experience
of the survivor?
Right. Because we use the the, the, the
contextualization Zisl to put the
survivor in a different story than
the one that he or she may be wanting to
tell.
So I'm wondering also if there's
something that Chad and Julie,
or Jonathan, you also want to address
how that, that tension.
Something that you might think about or
deal with in the way you're approaching
testimonies.
I don't know how to answer this yet, but
I think there's,
there's one interesting book I read
recently and reviewed
that might offer some
tips that Eva Noack-Mosse's
recently published memoir
of The Last Days of Theresienstadt
in that it's, it's a memoir
that she wrote, you might think of it as
a diary that she wrote as, as she was
in Theresienstadt.
And then she went back and tried to
mediate her own
diary. And the press attempted
to place all of her and
her postwar editions, all of her
additions to the book that were not
contemporaneous.
They tried to put all of those in
italics.
But if you go through it
with a fine tooth comb, you realize
there's a lot more mediation there than
they were able to get in the italics.
And it's kind of just...It's a
fascinating book.
It's almost like
it presupposes
these edited testimonies,
right? Because it's, it's the survivor
doing it themselves.
It's the, it's the individual who
experienced this, trying to mediate
their own early testimony
of those events and...
It's difficult to pick apart,
really difficult to pick apart what they
knew at the time and what they didn't,
but fascinating
in the attempt at least.
And you raise an interesting point about
survivors themselves and, you know,
the earlier
approach in reading these and listening
to these testimonies was more
historical.
Really, I think the Fortunoff, you know,
made huge strides in shifting
attention to the stories of suffering
and of themselves and to study the
trauma and to study, to listen to those
voices in of themselves and the
subjectivity of them.
But then it's yes, you have the other
phenomenon of the survivor who
adds his or her own contextualization
and pulls out history books while
they're narrating their own
autobiography and don't get it right all
the time or kind of,
you know, they don't tell us their own
personal stories. They tell us kind of
what is kind of common, common memory
versus their own
deeper memories. So it
can happen both by
scholars as well as by the survivors
themselves.
Yeah,
I mean, when, when looking at a
testimony, I'm reminded of something
that one of my professors actually in
England said to me and
he said historians, you know, we engage
in lumping and splitting and
into with testimonies, I, you know,
clearly we want something that's
representative and we
can, you know, gain insight
into, into, you know,
events that affected many more people.
But we also want to do the splitting
and preserve what is unique in the
individual, right, and, and to have a
voice and have an experience that is
exceptional. So it's always that
balancing act and,
between representativeness and
uniqueness in terms of the testimony.
But just to add that in terms of
everything else that was said that, that
I very much agree with.
You know, sometimes the over
contextualization is done, if it's not a
survivor testimony, this is,
you're going to think this is kind of a
strange comparison.
But think
about the fact that the
writings of perpetrators
are often heavily
contextualized by scholars because
we, you know, we want to, in a way
diminish the impact and the
resonance of that voice.
So a kind of, there's a decision
that's made and that kind of academic
research decision empirical--
She dropped.
Oh, we lost her.
Oh.
Yeah, OK, well, she'll come in.
Yeah, I was I was just thinking about
the name, the name just
escaped my mind, which I shouldn't.
But the book by another
professor here at Yale about...the image
of the genocide survivor is
the, Stephen is probably going to help
me recover the name,
the historical image of the survivor of
genocide as kind of
a general, where something represented
the general victim in the postwar period
looking for that, the
name of the book that's going to come
back
in a minute.
But just generally how, right, that
experience has, has become
kind of a cultural experience, rather
their unique and personal experience.
I think this is something that touched
what Wendy just said.
I would, I would also note that the
idea behind the Critical Edition
series is not exclusively this,
aimed at sort of deep
contextualization.
I mean, that's a part of the work, the
annotation,
but it's also about
seeing a testimony through the eyes
of the individual scholar who is working
with it. Right. Sort of.
And that's, that's an understanding
that, that's your, this is your
view of the value significance
of this testimony for historiographical
questions. It's not the only
meaning this, this testimony has.
It's through the eyes of you as
the, as the scholar.
And I would also note that, yeah,
I think this is a really, this is
something that we haven't discussed
enough. It's, it's still sort of new
for us.
But
in the end, the, the original document,
the sort of frozen moments of anguish,
et cetera, are in the audiovisual
recording.
And they're not, they're not,
I think,
made less powerful by this, this
textual contextualization.
Right.
It's another layer.
But I don't think it needs to be seen
as a sort of
a dangerous layer
that could remove the power of the
subjectivity of the testimony.
That's my hope.
Yeah. No, it's just something to be
aware of, you know, something
to kind of just, just think about,
because there is this impulse
academically to add
the layers, add the knowledge, do
the empirical work, especially on the
part of an historian, and to really kind
of, you know, present
that in a way and kind of show that off
as advances in knowledge.
Right. But the layering, the layering,
the layering, again,
that potential exists there.
That's all.
And I'll also note that another
goal of the contextualization, of
course, is that the recognition of just
how complicated these documents can be.
Right. And so, you know,
trying to learn about the history of the
Holocaust exclusively through survivor
testimony is very difficult,
if not impossible project.
So this contextualization is really,
ideally there to, to,
to help provide
the kind of understanding that might be
lost if, if, if there
was not a scholar with you to help you
guide you through this complex document,
at least.
That's one of the goals.
I agree, I agree with you, Stephen.
I think one of the things you get, that
you get from reading the Critical
Editions is, precisely looking at how
a scholar uses testimonies and what is
the whole richer world that she
or he brings and the kind of view of the
testimony.
And it tries to bring it just from a
story about the personal
experience of someone into a story
that is tied. So if you highlight a
certain place, if you know the place or
certain place was a place in which there
was, kind of anti-Jewish violence in the
years preceded that, or preceded the
war, you could have get a whole different
understanding of the relation
between the,
the testimony and
the context of, which I think,
definitely one of the things here is
not, it's not so much a question of do
we want, is there too much or too little
context? It's about showing how
often a context can, can offer one way
to enrich our understanding of this
testimony.
Does anyone else have,
you have any more questions from
the audience for the participants?
It was very
fascinating.
Your thoughts, very rich.
I can understand that people have a lot
to think about from four different
contexts and perspectives
here.
Well, I want to say one thing I
think is really interesting about the
possibilities of the Critical Editions.
In the testimonies that I'm often
using in my research, I'm trying to put
back together a cellular
resistance organization.
So by design, not everyone
knew about everyone.
And I learn almost as much
from what they don't know as what they
do know.
And were there to be a
great candidate for doing a Critical
Edition of a resistance
like that, you would learn so much if
you were the reader going through,
looking at, well, here's what the
witness knows and here's
what had to be filled in alongside
that. And I'm just, because of where
I'm coming from with my work, I'm really
fascinated by the chance to look
at those two things next to each other.
No, I have, I have to second that Chad.
I also think from the, what things that
I work on, there's always a gap of
knowledge by the person you're writing
about, not only so much.
Part of it is because during the
Holocaust, I mean, knowledge was so
sporadic and putting things together
is a hard task.
Some people's knowledge might be
confined to the period in which he
lives. He doesn't know what's going to
happen next. And we have that foresight
or that knowledge or just because of the
geographical location and so
forth. But I totally agree with that.
And one thing you'll see too in terms of
knowledge is
the inconsistencies that are,
that can be there.
Sydney Bruskin was asked by the
Fortunoff interviewers several times
what he knew about
camps prior to entering into Ebensee.
And he completely contradicted himself
in the process at times, that
he had no idea about camps and he just
sort of stumbled into them, this one.
And I would, I had never seen or imagine
anything like this.
And in other times in the testimony he
says, "yeah, we had, we heard
from our other GIs that there were these
camps and, just to realize
that it's messy sometimes
and that there is conflict.
And we have to factor in that, as we
understand.
So I think on this note,
I'm going to, to end this
event and I want to thank again all the
speakers for their wonderful thoughts
and presentations and,
and I look forward to reading some
of the Critical Editions that are going
to come out. I think we all look forward
to reading the Critical Editions that
are going to come out from this work in
the coming months.
And thank you, everyone, for coming
and attending and listening to this
event.
Stephen, would you like to add anything
or?
No, thanks. Thanks to everyone.
This is great.
And thanks to our listeners for, for
sticking with us to the very end.
Thank you, Gil. Thank you, David.
Thanks.
Thank you,
Chad.
Yeah.